hi there this is John green of the
vlogbrothers and you're watching truth
or fail
YouTube's bone Lee game show bone Lee of
course is a word that means probably
only and definitely best he is an
example of a lie and that my friends is
your job here at truth or fail I tell
you to purported facts and then you use
your little cursor to click on the truth
or you fail now you may be asking
yourself John why are you wearing a
zombified unicorn head the answer should
be obvious I'm wearing a zombified
unicorn head because I can okay so
today's episode of truth or fail
contains facts that you should know
regardless of whether you've read my
books but you could have learned from
reading my books alright are you ready
Zomba fight unicorn are you ready yes
man I should get out of the novel
writing game and become a ventriloquist
okay time for your first set of facts
fact 1 the American Civil War General
John said to its last words were they
couldn't hit an elephant at this dist or
fact 2 the American poet Emily
Dickinson's last words were doctor do
you think it was the sausage
[Music]